Kim Jong-Il was born Yuri Irsenovich Kim.
His official biography states that he was
born on a sacred mountain (Baekdu Mountain,
the legendary birthplace of Korea’s first
kingdom) on February 16, 1942, where his father
was serving in a secret military base, attempting
to overthrow the Japanese. Further, it states
that his birth was marked by a double rainbow
over the mountain, a new star appearing in
the sky, and, before his birth, a swallow
foretold his coming.
Besides the obvious parts of this that aren’t
true, he also was not born on Baekdu Mountain
in 1942, but rather was born in Vyatskoye,
Khabaroskv in 1941. Vyatskoye is a small hamlet
in Russia. Kim’s father, Kim Il-Sung, was
actually a commander in the Soviet 88th Brigade
there. After WWII, Korea gained its independence
from Japan and the family returned to Korea
where his father began being groomed to rule
by the Soviets, first being installed by Stalin
as the head of the Provisional People’s
Committee. Shortly thereafter, he was made
Prime Minister and eventually became President.
Other interesting Korean state propaganda
surrounding Kim Jong-Il include:
He never pooped (perhaps that contributed
to his declining health).
He wrote over 1,500 books in a three year
time-span.
He wrote six full operas that are considered
by experts to be the best six operas ever
created.
The first time he played golf in 1994, he
shot 11 hole-in-ones and was 38 under par
(verified by all of his bodyguards, no less).
From there, he nearly always shot several
hole-in-ones any time he golfed.
He began walking at just three weeks old and
could fluently speak at just eight weeks old.
People the world over receive plastic surgery
to try to look more like Kim Jong-Il. His
hair and clothing styles are also widely mimicked.
His birthday is highly celebrated throughout
the world.
He had the ability to control the weather
and it usually reflected his moods.
He invented hamburgers as a way to provide
a new tasty food for his impoverished people.